Do I, as a traditional wife,
think women should work?
Starting off,
I don't think there's anything wrong with a woman
having a job.
I know that might come as a shock
because people think.
We think women can only stay home.
I don't believe that.
Um, I've never believed that.
Do, however, think that being home is very important.
Especially if you have young children in the home.
Um, like toddlers and stuff.
I don't think it's healthy
to have them in daycare all day.
I think that they need to be with mom.
But I also understand that, you know,
it's not possible for everyone to be home.
I totally fully grasp that.
I think a woman's priority should be her home. So
if your job is pulling you too much away from the home
and the well being of your family,
then I think that is a problem.
But other than that, no,
I think it's great if women work.
If they wanna work, great.
I personally do not want a 9 to 5.
I really like staying home and being home
and doing the things that I do in my home.
Um, but again,
if women wanna make income to help their husbands,
by all mean, do it.
There's also ways you can do that from home.
You just gotta get really creative today.
Work is a good thing.
Work is a part of being human.
It gives you a purpose,
it gives you an identity.
And if that is better fulfilled for a woman,
I guess outside of the homes,
by all means,
go for it. Um,
but work outside the home is work,
and work inside of the home is work.
So they're both work.